de Marseille à Héricourt de Montargis à
Lyon d'Échirolles à Nanterre dans tous
les territoires abandonnés des villes
aux campagnes la révolte à déchiré la
France car voilà 18 années que les
politiques échouent 18 années depuis la
mort de Ziad Bena et Bouna Traoré et
aujourd'hui c'est Naël qui est tué
18 années de stérilité de
rationalisation et de disparition des
services publics 18 années durant
lesquelles le contrat républicain a été
bafoué s'il vous plaît car la réalité
madame la Première ministre et qu'en
France aujourd'hui certaines vies valent
moins que d'autres certains territoires
valent moins que d'autres en France
l'égalité est un concept théorique
brûler des écoles pillées des magasins
agressés des élus ne seront jamais des
actes de justice la violence ne pourra
pas être la solution c'est pourquoi nous
écologistes nous membres de la nupesse
nous ne nous résignons pas un monde où
certains ont tout et d'autres ne sont
rien il n'y a pas de fatalité notre est
responsabilité d'avoir une réponse
politique d'abord l'acte d'apaisement
annoncer la modification de la loi de
2017 annoncer le retour de la police de
proximité et mettez en place
immédiatement des mesures de lutte
contre les discriminations et contre le
racisme ensuite l'humilité les
politiques ne pourront jamais réussir
seul écouter les fonctionnaires les
associations de terrain les mers et les
parents pas seulement deux heures en
période de crise mais toute l'année et
enfin investissez dans la jeunesse il
nous faut une vraie politique de
jeunesse et faites de l'école publique
une priorité sans une école qui
fonctionne pas d'égalité madame la
Première ministre quand cesserez-vous
d'être pétrifié et comprendrez-vous
enfin les mesures fortes pour recréer et
réparer et recréer les liens que vous
avez laissés se désagréger
[Musique]
la parole
la parole est à madame la Première
ministre madame la Présidente Mesdames
et Messieurs les Députés madame la
Présidente Cyrielle châtelain vous
l'avez rappelé il y a une semaine le
drame de la mort d'un jeune homme de 17
ans lors d'un contrôle routier a
beaucoup choqué à travers notre pays
face à ce drame les viols les réponses
viendront de la justice et pas de la
violence et vous l'avez dit vous-même
pourtant depuis une semaine des
violences inacceptables ont éclatées
dans certaines communes ces violences
vous les avez condamnées et je veux
saluer cette attitude républicaine qui
tranche avec celle de certains de vos
alliés mais madame la Présidente
Chatelain c'est violence n'ont rien à
voir avec une révolte des banlieues et
j'ai été madame la Présidente Chatelain
à Nanterre à Garges-lès-Gonesse à Bezons
à Évry à L'Haÿ-les-Roses j'ai changé
avec les élus et les habitants et deux
mots revenaient sans cesse
l'incompréhension et la colère la colère
vis-à-vis de ses auteurs de violence qui
met des politiques menées depuis des
années tous les efforts qui ont été
faits pour la politique de la ville
notamment dans le précédent quinquennat
pour rénover ses quartiers pour
reconstruire des équipements publics
pour renforcer l'accès aux services
publics dans ces quartiers et vis-à-vis
de la jeunesse madame la Présidente
Chatelain nous avons agi tout au long du
président précédent quinquennat nous
avons agi tout au long du précédent
quinquennat avec le développement de
l'apprentissage avec les emplois francs
avec aujourd'hui la réforme du lycée
professionnel donc madame la Présidente
Chatelain c'est violences sont
inexcusables elles ne représentent pas
la jeunesse de notre pays nous
accompagnons tous les Français tous les
jeunes dans tous les dans tous les
territoires de notre République je vous
remercie
merci beaucoup madame la Première
ministre
[Applaudissements]